ahora vamos a hablar sobre la idea de
impedancia que es una idea muy
importante en la electrónica y es algo
que viene del análisis sea el análisis
sea es cuando limitamos la alimentación
de nuestros circuitos con entradas que
son senoidal es que son senos y cosenos
de todas las señales que podríamos tener
en el universo nos vamos a limitar de
momento a tener solamente onda senoidal
es pues hay cosas que se simplifican
mucho si hacemos esto en este vídeo
vamos a desarrollar las ecuaciones y ver
para nuestros tres componentes pasivos
favoritos resistencia inductor y
capacitor y los analizaremos cuando la
entrada es senoidal esto significa que
ya sea y ub el voltaje o la corriente
tienen forma senoidal veremos qué
significa esto para las ecuaciones y ve
con nuestros dispositivos favoritos
veamos nuestras ecuaciones y ven con
entradas senoidal es en donde
descomponemos estas senoidal es en
exponenciales complejas
estudiamos las unidades vemos que
podemos descomponer las en exponenciales
complejas usando las ecuaciones de hoy
leer si tenemos una onda coseno que sea
una función del tiempo coseno omega t
que podemos expresar en términos de
exponenciales complejos de esta manera
es igual a un medio por el ala más j
omega t más el ala - j omega t
y lo que vamos a hacer ahora es ver qué
sucede cuando usamos esto como una señal
de entrada aunque esta no es una señal
de entrada real es un vector imaginario
que gira pero si tuviera dos de estos
podría reensamblada los en una onda cosa
no nos gusta usar estos exponenciales
porque pasan por las ecuaciones
diferenciales de un circuito muy
fácilmente estas son las entradas que
sabemos cómo resolver cuando hacemos
ecuaciones diferenciales lo que voy a
hacer es desarrollar las ecuaciones y
ver para la resistencia inductor y
capacitor en términos de este tipo de
entrada cuando el voltaje o la corriente
luces y veremos cómo lucen las
ecuaciones vamos a comenzar con la
resistencia r aquí está la resistencia y
sabemos por la ley de ohm que b es igual
a por r
y por el momento vamos a suponer que la
corriente y es igual a e a la j omega t
positivo a la j omega t positivo si esto
es y cuál será la b para esta
resistencia sustituimos y acá y nos
queda que es igual a r porque a la j
omega t positivo ahora vamos a hacer
algo que puede parecer muy simple pero
que se va a poner interesante quiero ver
la proporción de voltaje a corriente en
esta situación cuando la alimentación es
esta exponencial compleja el voltaje es
r por y al aj omega t positivo si hago
pasar esta corriente a través de la
resistencia
a la jota omega t positivo a que es
igual esto estas dos son iguales por lo
que se cancelan y tengo que la
proporción de voltaje a la corriente es
igual a r para una resistencia así que
para una resistencia
acabamos de probar que ve entre y es
igual a r
esto no es novedad es simplemente la ley
de ohm y para una resistencia el voltaje
entre la corriente siempre será igual a
la resistencia esto se pondrá más
interesante
conforme veamos el inductor y el
capacitor ahora hagamos el inductor el
que tiene un valor de l henri y para un
inductor
sabemos que el voltaje de es igual a él
por la derivada de la corriente con
respecto al tiempo hagamos lo mismo y
digamos que es igual a e a la jota omega
t positiva es una corriente exponencial
compleja que hacemos que pase a través
de nuestro inductor ahora encontremos a
b b es igual a él por de entre de t por
e a la jota omega t positivo hombre es
igual hacemos la derivada de esto y el
término j omega bajan para multiplicar a
l es igual a j
omega l por lo mismo que a la j omega t
positivo
lo hermoso de las exponenciales se
regresan a ellas mismas ahora veamos
cuál es la proporción de voltaje a
corriente de entre y es igual a el
voltaje j
omega l y al aj omega t positivo y vamos
a dividir esto entre iu y al aj omega t
positivo estos se cancelan y nos queda
de entre y igual a j omega por l
ahora tenemos una ecuación de entre y
para un inductor lo que es interesante
porque ahora tenemos el valor de la
inductancia que esperábamos y también
tenemos este término j omega omega es la
frecuencia por lo que esto nos dice que
la proporción debe ahí para un inductor
depende de la frecuencia haremos lo
mismo para el capacitor pse y el valor
de su capacitancia está enfadado y
sabemos que para el capacitor y es igual
hace por la derivada del voltaje con
respecto al tiempo
en esta ocasión haremos que b sea igual
a la jota omega t positivo por lo que
ahora haremos que un voltaje que es esta
exponencial compleja pase a través de un
capacitor pongamos esto aquí y nos
quedan y igual hace por de entre de t
por e a la jota omega t positivo lo que
nos da y igual y ocurre lo mismo el
término de j omega baja a multiplicar a
stacet es igual a jota omega c por el a
la j omega t positivo nos hacemos la
misma pregunta que nos hicimos con
anterioridad a que es igual b entre y
para un capacitor sustituimos ven que es
y al aj omega t positivo y la corriente
la tenemos acá j omega c
por e a la jota omega t positivo
estos se cancelan y para un capacitor
nos queda de / y es igual a 1 / j omega
se resaltamos esto también y nos dice
que la proporción voltaje a corriente
para un capacitor va a depender del
valor de la capacitancia y también va a
depender de la frecuencia muy parecido
al inductor que también tiene un término
de la frecuencia la proporción de
voltaje a corriente en los tres casos
tiene un nombre especial que es
impedancia y el símbolo que usamos para
representar la impedancia es una zeta la
palabra impedancia se refiere a la idea
general de la proporción voltaje a
corriente y podemos tenerla para estos
tres componentes para una resistencia la
impedancia es la resistencia r por lo
que la palabra impedancia es similar a
la palabra resistencia la excepción de
que la impedancia es un concepto más
general del voltaje dividido entre la
corriente
una resistencia la impedancia es su
resistencia para un inductor la
impedancia de entrada es j omega él y
para el capacitor su impedancia es 1 / j
omega c de aquí viene esta idea de
impedancia y esta idea incluye tanto a
los valores de los componentes como el
efecto que tiene la frecuencia en la
proporción en voltaje corriente así que
ambas cosas se combinan en la misma idea
en resumen la impedancia de una
resistencia es igual a r la impedancia
de un inductor es igual a j omega l y la
impedancia de un capacitor va a ser
igual a 1 / j
omega c para recordar las suposiciones
que hicimos de que solamente vamos a
considerar entradas sinusoidales o
senoidal es y qué descompusimos dichas
senoidal es nuestra onda coseno en estas
exponenciales complejas
vemos que estos vectores que giran pasan
a través de nuestros componentes en
forma de voltajes o corrientes aquí no
hay nada nuevo lo que pasa es que
tomamos estas notas o megas que salieron
de las exponenciales cuando hicimos las
derivadas y las asocia mos con el mismo
componente hicimos eso aquí y aquí esto
fue como un truco en la anotación
asociamos esta dependencia a la
frecuencia no con las entradas de los
voltajes y las corrientes sino con los
mismos componentes y nos referimos a
esto como transformaciones o vamos a
transformar los componentes de aquí
viene la idea de impedancia en el
sentido general de la proporción voltaje
a corriente